yeah okay see we carry the Zipit
instantly I know patience is the key put
enough on my ship for free
this is tea we carry feet Michael make
your friend good morning everyone
just finishing writing up to these long
texts you sit through it morning good
morning morning morning to tea with Gary
B we are in starting to get towards mid
bay and we're in it
good morning everybody on C Twitter
Facebook YouTube twitch great to see all
of you this morning which have two backs
Brian and body
it's got Paschal we see Ashlyn good to
see you flip daddy babes what's good
said tesha so chela lee what's what's up
Andy s KJ Delmer hunter Boone and all of
my other friends please take a
screenshot of this and share the URL
that you have in your browser right now
and get your homies and your friends on
here Destin good morning how was your
weekend
excellent like Bill and Ted's exactly
and watch that in a long time actually
they made a new one right super oh I
thought it was just in like a talks of a
new one but I don't know I don't
remember all right let's get in the show
cool
good morning good morning what's your
name Adelita meet you nice to meet you
too Gary how's it going super well thank
you good what's cookin yeah
nothing I'm over here it's 6:00 a.m. my
time I'm on the west coast so I have my
coffee next to me and I want to talk
today a little bit about tick-tock so I
know you're obviously on there
I am also active on there I was pretty
quick to jump on it because I saw an
opportunity and I wanted to be kind of
ahead of the curve so let's talk about
the strategy behind it I'm past the
point of should I be on there what is
the best strategy on actually being
there the how many times should you post
today what kind of content do you find a
niche you know how long should the video
be those are the types of questions I
have more about strategy versus should I
get on tick-tock you know so early
things I'm seeing is one there there
doesn't seem to be at this point any
disadvantage at posting as often as
possible you see some people posting as
many as ten times a day yeah and we and
reaping the benefits so times a day I
like to throw out three and four because
I think it's truly manageable mm-hmm if
you're fully ambitious and all the way
there and you're over the mental hurdle
of worrying about likes and yeah I'm
good to say as far as what to put out I
always think that the right strategy is
putting out what you want versus what
you think is working yeah so you know
when I got an Instagram what was working
was incredible photography and Surin was
a photography right right and my mean
business and mind set content like do
you know and it took a little while but
it really then kind of kicked in and so
if you look at Twitter if you look at
MySpace right myspace was music hard
yeah music and then Tila Tequila and
Dane Cook and others could win on that
platform comedians models thinks that
nature so as far as what to put out I
think that you need to put out what you
want to be talking about however is
being thoughtful about copy overlay what
song to use in the background using the
hash tag for European you know you know
for you page you know my PE things like
that so there are tactics within it well
I would but if you're but if you want to
talk about you know hiking I don't think
you should go and start twerking do you
know what I mean yeah
yeah yeah so and then there's duets
medley action videos there's there's
subtle tactics within the platform there
is the ability to DM and reach out to do
collaborations there's the ability to
use your Instagram stories and your
Instagram feed and your Twitter account
to build awareness towards your tik-tok
yeah a lot of strategies underneath
there you know yeah have you seen a
shift of the people who follow on other
platforms go to tick tock or brand new
audience I feel like there are a lot
younger
from my perspective my normal
demographic would be women who are 25 to
45 and tick tock you've got like the 14
year-olds you think they've got life all
figured out so have you seen kind of
that younger shift yeah I think the
platform skews younger but I think over
the last six months it's gotten
dramatically older yeah and I think
within a year it becomes kind of
omnipresent from six to forty five
meaning anybody's kind of on it yeah and
and then it just kind of goes back to my
point always which is a play the
platform's destined to be a major
platform and sticks around for three
years in that three years of its heat
moment it will hit every demo except
kind of fifty-two older and then yeah
then you need another kind of three to
five years to go fifty and older like
you've seen what they spot Facebook and
like you've seen with Instagram yeah you
know that's kind of where I think it's
at right now yeah so trajectory do you
think tech talk will be around for a
little bit longer when you mentioned
myspace that was kind of the first
social media I was ever on so it's
interesting you know obviously that's
not really used as much anymore so do
you see trajectory of you know longer
life span I think platforms are like TV
shows you know some shows are destined
to be hot for 24 months vine TV shows
Empire others other shows are destined
for 15 20 year runs the essence Facebook
so you know I'm not crippled by that
because whatever audience you're able to
build on tick-tock
you're able to build awareness in that
platform and then when jig jaw comes out
and we all go there when you go over
there of certain percentage of your [ __ ]
audience comes along yeah right you know
if I hadn't built everything that I've
built in other platforms there's no way
I'm at 3.5 million followers on
tick-tock right so I think too many
people worry about like is this a fad
that's what people told me about the
internet in 1996 when I launched my
library com it's not about that it's
about when something's on fire you play
it and then when it's not it's not when
a club is hot you go there when it
Peters out you go to the next hot club
yeah when a restaurant is [ __ ] the
[ __ ] you go and eat there and when it's
not you don't and for some reason on
social networks people are so audacious
about wasting their time mm-hmm without
realizing what they should be doing is
marketing on the platform and extracting
brand values absolutely I love it thank
you so much you're welcome to take care
Guerry Hawaii how are you yeah not bad
has a healthy weekend awesome yeah not
pretty good it's um currently 11 o'clock
here in Australia but so yeah I'm a full
time wedding filmmaker
um my younger brother and I own a
wedding film business and we've been
doing that for about three or four years
now I've recently actually decided to
start a personal brand around um
creating free content on teaching
wedding films and I actually just
started the tic-tock probably bout a
week ago you can get up you from not
doing that sooner but uh just doing like
were free sort of wedding tips for
brides and so awesome I was telling my
mom about this idea and by the way like
my mom's awesome
both my parents always supporting
everything I'll do but she brought the
point that if I'm sharing our tips and
tricks wouldn't that essentially create
more competition for ourselves but um
but that's not really my question my
question was because you're just gonna
be thinking how exactly do we
distinguish between opinions and like
actual advice um it's a really good
question so I think it comes down to a
couple things one I always judge the
person that is giving the opinion or the
advice so how many big businesses has
your mom built zero that's a good
starting point right she to your point
she's fantastic and she's so supportive
and I think her opinion slash advice on
this issue has a validity right there is
a lot of common sense to the notion of
if you're giving away your secrets are
you putting yourself in a vulnerable
spot the reality is my opinion after 22
years of doing business professionally
and longer intuitively as a kid is the
world is abundant and winners win and I
think the way the internet works with
branding I actually think you gain
business I mean I've lived that life
right there's plenty of people have
taken my advice and packaged it up and
sold it against my own fan base and I've
been able to extract money out of my fan
base by repackaging what I do for free
and it's silly to watch and I laugh at
it but I don't think it's come at my
expense
so I think my biggest barometer between
opinion and advices first advices
opinion and opinion is advice and costia
what I spend all my time on is judging
the person who delivered it and then
people when somebody even when Jeff
Bezos would give me advice I would say
okay but he's coming from the
perspective of how Amazon was built and
I think that could be the case or if I
paid attention to him one of the things
that I spent a lot of time on is not
giving advice or opinions or thoughts or
hyperbole around how it happened for me
for me it's more about observations not
what happened with me obviously there's
some things that have happened with me
and so that's kind of a that's kind of
how I see it right yeah cuz I guess you
know obviously being in a position where
I'm obviously still learning and maybe
maybe I can't judge like maybe I can't
accurately judge whether they know what
they're talking about or not so
obviously with you I know a lot about
you I've been following you for a few
years now and so I trust and I know you
should say you shouldn't you know always
trust even your opinion but or your
advice but obviously I know that your
your comments are gonna have more weight
or more validity behind someone you know
Joe down the street so I guess it's just
that coming from that position of yeah
judging you know whether they have that
validity or not which altima led me to
not listening to anybody but valuing the
experience over opinion yes and not
being fearful of being wrong yep sounds
pretty simple all of it simple we make
it go yes yeah I think we overthink
things a lot of the time thank you
awesome
cheese Gary thanks peers all right hey
Dustin yeah
am I not coming in good see some people
it's a little on the quiet side I just
heard your mom laughs huh
[Applause]
test test yellow one second what about
now that's better
can hear you better all right let's rock
and roll cool yeah Daniel what's good
what's up I just wanted to say thank you
so I'm from Australia as well from
Melbourne so it's nighttime here it
seems to be thanks thanks it's a day for
Australia I just want to say thank you
so much this opportunity this has been
this has been a journey and you know
really looking forward to talking you
I'm a bit nervous as well so and what I
want to start with a little bit about my
background just to lead up to my
question so so basically when I was like
6 years old my grandmother passed away
he was very close with and similar to
you I come from a like half Russian and
polish background on my mom side and
Italian on my dad so I experienced sort
of like lost at a very early age when I
was 10 my mom was diagnosed with cancer
and she got sick and then when I was 16
she passed away so I went through quite
a lot of stuff in my life and after I
finished high school here in you know
when I was 18 I I really struggled like
mentally it was hard to finish school I
went through a lot of depression I went
through all sorts of challenges and
source other thoughts and that kind of
stuff and I really went through like the
dark night of the soul and so at about
25 I started to sort of come out of that
and you know I Here I am today and I'm
I'm doing good and I want to help people
I've been to a lot of stuff I put a lot
of work on myself I've done a lot of
things to improve myself so I want to
give you that backdrop so the question I
have for you is despite having followed
you for a while and also all this
investment I've done into myself I feel
like I'm still operating at 40 or 50
percent of my potential and I I sabotage
myself I'll hold myself back and I know
that what I
to saying what I have to what I want to
give to people is so valuable but yet
there's a part of me that it's
conflicting that I'd like value myself
at times and then I don't value myself
and then I'm fearful of trying to sell
myself similar to like Danielle from
Friday like I like that like I know so
much that I have good intentions like
I'm coming from a heart space but what
are you trying to sell well at this
point that's the thing I mean so I used
to be a personal trainer and I studied
also holistic health so I want to get
into the speaking realm and world and
what I'm thinking of doing now is I
already have a brand name for the
business which is head body but at the
moment I'm working on the personal brand
which is obviously my name and I want to
combine sort of the how to help people
in their life with all the holistic
aspects so not just the mental side but
the nutrition and the diet and all that
other stuff you know hydration and your
thoughts because they all play a role so
I want to combine both worlds okay but
but I it's kind of funny because like I
was originally asked to be on the show
on Thursday and so it was like
last-minute type thing and I felt like
you were like Jedi Mind [ __ ] me
because like I felt you I felt you I
just heard your voice like put out all
content put out more content so like
Friday I didn't get on and it's just
been like I've had this extra day so
I've been really trying to put out as
much content as I can
what have you noticed in those four days
um in terms of what particularly
anything have you you know because the
reality is there's so many people that
want to speak want a coach you want to
build a personal brand and the problem
is to be successful in that you need
leverage you need people to give a [ __ ]
and though and the way to give a get
people to give a [ __ ] is to put out
ungodly amounts of content for free and
to speak for free before people are
willing to pay you because what you're
doing is building brand you know most
people confuse sales and branding and
marketing and so there is no shortcut to
building a brand Nike almost went out of
business seven years into its company
but people are wildly confused
there's fourth billion gary vaynerchuk's
and Daniel ELLs and so you know I get it
like everybody feels like they have to
something to say I mean that they know
every single person actually feels like
they have something to say the the
separation is the execution yeah yeah I
actually was thinking about that too and
then thinking about actually wanting to
ask you that because I literally part
one of the questions are sent in so you
guys was was exactly that how do I get
people to give a [ __ ] enough to hear
what I have to say how do you earn a
nice crop by building out by putting out
your best troops like by being honest by
talking about things you know by telling
stories on this page that I have here
that's what I'm doing I don't ask for
anything I don't have any products at
the moment to sell I'm just giving
everything the biggest the biggest issue
I see in the market is a lot of people
start something they hear me then they
realize I'm not gonna give I'm gonna
give away for free but in the back of
their mind
they know that they're going in for the
sale at some point and that and that
polar push really is a struggle you know
like it's a struggle like I think that a
lot of like to me the best way to
eventually start a business is once the
demands there a lot of people try to
create the demand but subconsciously not
even consciously subconsciously they're
building only towards eventually having
the product they focus on things like
the name of the company like you do you
know the name doesn't mean anything
literally zero you the name of your
company and brand actually means zero
the ability to build it is everything
names are made the [ __ ] does Google mean
or Nike or beats by dre or Under Armour
or champion or sprayground adidas then
these [ __ ] things mean dick nobody
gives a [ __ ] coca-cola they were made
names are names don't matter you know
mister you know my name is Gary
Vaynerchuk if I was built you know I
made it not like my name's not Johnny
[ __ ] wonderful you know it means
people are just super confused by that
they spend time on the name
they you you and I don't I don't judge
this I have empathy for this your your
thinking about what product and service
are you eventually gonna sell again
conscious or not you need them you're
building money I get it you know one of
the great advantages I have is I don't
have a framework that monetizes my
audience I know like when you're not
Gary Vee and you don't need to monetize
your audience and it's no I'm not trying
to monetize mordents in the sense of
like maliciousness or i agree i agree i
don't want to work like i was washing
dishes for my dad oh that's my dad but i
was i was washing dishes for my dad you
know doing a job that really made me
miserable
prior to coat it and so i I don't want
to do that job that you always say you
know go do that shitty job so you can
build this thing so like is that
possible though to do that can i because
i said of course it's possible but you
have to understand supply and demand
they're literally right now 15 200
million people trying to do the same
exact thing as you are so so when i tell
people to tell their story and to stay
in their Lane their only way to win is
to make it super personal the only
reason i break through and others break
through is it's my truth people can
follow me and make quote cards and put
on their Instagram and I cam why does
Gary feat [ __ ] you know when he's
just saying the same motivational thing
no I'm not I'm saying my thing my truth
my actual truth hmm so I think you need
to your breakthrough isn't your actual
truth
well it's your lisa is with like tick
tock like I started tick tock and I
noticed I was like I put out a video and
it just it was one of the trends and I
was like I felt so [ __ ] about it I was
like this isn't me like this is what's
trending and what's gonna get hits and
it didn't and it probably didn't cuz my
feeling was like different so I actually
put out a video today which was so much
more my truth and I was like I felt so
good about it and I didn't care as much
about the about how many follow or how
many views I got cuz it just felt real
like alright Dean do you know in the
early years my favorite part of not
having anybody watch it was knowing one
day everybody would watch it you know
how do you get
how do you truck that stuff because I'm
good at what I do you need to you need
to make you have to have a sense of like
do you think you know I'm good at being
fully me I'm good at telling my [ __ ] to
your point yeah you know what do you
think it's gonna take then for me tell
me I think it should take you telling
stories about the darkness about that
loss about where you were about things
you've seen things you learned washing
dishes things you learn you know just
stories - stories true stories it seems
like a strength for me but sometimes it
can be a weakness I feel but I'm very
open with with my stuff because I want
it to come from a place where it's not
like me me me it's more like I get you
like I want to relate to people and and
then help guide them through their own
stuff
based on what I've also experienced I
totally understand and I think the way
you do that is volume across the board
volume across the board be everywhere
you know like to me I'm actually on a
mission and I think a lot of people
aren't like a half pregnant mission hmm
you know like I'm genuinely on that same
mission bro I've seen what you talked
about with death and stuff I think about
all the time like and legacy and like
what I want to be mourn for and how I
like what country like my life my whole
life's purpose if I'm gonna go through
all this loss and stuff you know you had
Eric Thomas on dailyvee I think or one
of those one of the shows you go and he
says something like you know you're
gonna go to all this paint get something
out of your paint so it's like I feel
like how old are you i'm gonna i'm
actually this is a really birthday
present I'm turning 31 on Sunday happy
birthday bro bro when I was when I was
when I turned 30 I had made at that
point in my life I'd made zero zero
content for the internet in my entire
life oh I just thought of my pleasure
good definitely definitely realize we
haven't even like we're just in the
beginning like definitely realize that
so let me ask you like do you think I
given one what we just spoke about I
like if I don't want to do those shitty
jobs are you telling me that I have to
just do those shitty jobs so that I can
avoid monetizing or trying to create a
product or no I'm telling you that if
you try to monetize and sell to your
audience when you don't have one it's
not going to go out it's literally like
going into a mixed martial arts UFC
match never training who the [ __ ]
gonna buy from you when you've done
nothing for them [ __ ] do you
know how many [ __ ] things I've done
for everybody in this audience that they
still haven't signed up for wine texts
and I've asked for it all month
we got your lines like sinisterly no but
do you know what I mean Daniel like like
like you know trying to get your
audience to convert is is very very very
difficult and most people most people
there's only two ways to do it my way
which is build a brand for so goddamn
long that you actually build such a deep
relationship that most people that most
people get into a place where they're
almost guilted you know like I feel like
a lot of people are signing up or wine
sex right now just cuz like damn like do
I buy wine from somebody else Gary's
brought me so much or the bizarro
reverse version of me they [ __ ] lie
they [ __ ] make people feel like [ __ ]
there's a two ways to have a good
relationship either build them up
there's two ways to have a long-standing
relationship one you build a person up
and you give them so much love and
you're building them up and because of
that you stay together - you actually
tear them down and make them so insecure
they don't feel that they can leave it's
on some Star Wars [ __ ] bro the fine line
between [ __ ] the dark side and Jedi's
is this [ __ ] narrow yeah the people
that look like me on Instagram that are
making that money 90% of them are
putting their audience in unhealthy
relationships that are selling them fear
and [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah agree I'm
selling happiness hope and truth and
practicality and
fine line in the beginning is super
close people think that me and other
people are the same and in 20 years
they'll realize we were completely
[ __ ] different yeah I'm hearing that
from you just change them meeting me
because what you just said about like no
one gives a [ __ ] who I am and no one
knows who the [ __ ] I am like I've got
like 80 followers are just out of my
page like few weeks ago or something you
know on Instagram at least and I've got
the same handle and Twitter and tic toc
as well but how do I so I still feel a
bit confused about I totally understand
what you're saying about not trying to
monetize because who the [ __ ] am I I'm
very humble I'm no issue in accepting
that and the second the second you
monetize every person that comes
starting to person 200 on is gonna see
that you're about that selling [ __ ] life
then there's a million of [ __ ] you
look at people who stumble on me how
many people in the comments say say me
right now in the comments we're like
we're waiting for the other shoe to drop
for me to sell you my course or my
[ __ ] off site or my [ __ ] you know
island or like like people like take a
long time like waiting they're like
alright this guy can't be really doing
this like this guy's wait he's just he's
just about to you know yeah yeah it's
like people want wanna buy from you like
they literally I Gary when it we have no
no no I would argue the other thing that
they couldn't believe like why would I
do this because they didn't know me yet
they didn't know that my entire business
life was elsewhere well that's the thing
if my business life is focused on this
stuff and so then what a wide literally
patience but what do I do if you're with
what do I do for money if I don't want
to I don't know but I don't know like
here's the fun part of it it's fun to
say I don't know because you don't want
to do other things which is amazing yeah
but I'm gonna say it again
some people don't want to train for 13
weeks after training for 10 years for
their first UFC fight and they get their
[ __ ] ass beat bro you're gonna get
your ass beat hmm what's
gonna happen you're gonna go in with
that you know $49 product that you and
Renaud product and what cumber to people
and then what exactly once now you've
now you've now you [ __ ] went for the
[ __ ] kill now what now you've changed
your relationship and your brand which
is okay it's let me say this very clear
it is wildly okay to sell like who knows
I might wake up in four years but [ __ ]
it I'm charging $10,000 a month to be in
T with Kerry be four days a week and
that's what I'm gonna do I don't give a
[ __ ] like it's everything's okay it's
just it's just sells something you
believe it in and also know when you go
in for the ask that if it doesn't
convert now you don't have the leverage
do you think I'll feel more like I'll
have more value in myself because I've
always struggled to sell even though
I've like always wanted to genuinely
smell like when I was a trainer I always
felt guilty like I'm robbing someone but
at the same time everything that I can
bring dude Daniel it's it's because you
didn't believe in the product which I
promise you there's bro you how long
have you followed me couple years good
you know any businesses I have but if
I'm not promoting them I don't feel like
it's bringing the most value it's even
it's even the biggest insight to mine
text ID so know how good it is that's
why I got loud I had five sneakers with
k-swiss
I had different nests with them
completely predicated the economics were
the same completely predicated on my own
personal opinion on if it was worth 90
bucks the reason so many people struggle
to sell is they don't believe in what
the [ __ ] selling and then you have a
small group of people you have a small
group of people that make a lot of money
quickly cuz they don't give a [ __ ] about
anything they have no conscience and
they sell everything as if it's the best
but they're [ __ ] dirt they're broken
their short-term right and then you have
this small percent you know the whole
mass of the middle of the night ninety
percent right here just completely or
lost you know like right and then like
just they don't believe in what they're
selling
you've got five percent over here who
wins short-term they have a good run for
five or seven years
they're the ones that go bankrupt
they're the ones who got [ __ ] up drug
problems like all sorts of [ __ ] they're
the ones that just sell on with no
conscious they don't give up they are so
broken they can't care about you
they don't care about themselves then
you have a small group that I hang out
with the other 5% that are in it for so
long that they build brands bro I
haven't even started
every [ __ ] percent of Earth is gonna
know who I am how do you how do you know
when you're ready to make the switch
from from giving giving giving to then
asking when you genuinely can't breathe
without telling people about something
to buy Kip reap it has nothing to do
with the metrics of anything of course
not that's the people that win for five
minutes hmm
what do you think I can do to get more
engagement on things like Instagram like
what I didn't I'm not not worrying about
the engagement by putting out your
clucking truth I made wine videos on
YouTube in 2006 when it was just pirated
content nobody gave a [ __ ] but I gave a
[ __ ] I started making social media
content when 95% of the world
ninety-eight percent the world didn't
know what social media was bro it's a
marathon
everyone's every question you've asked
is a short-term question no no I know
you know I think for you the formula
like if you were my best homie I'd be
like bro you have to find a side hustle
that mean teens so that you can go long
on the thing that you want to be yeah
yeah you sir I'm going so I like flip
it's why I like flipping so much it
teaches people how to market it teaches
people of that supply and demand
mm-hmm you know just everything retail
arbitrage go into a discount store in
Australia and flipping it like you know
like like I love that stuff so I got a
bounce to ask you anything real quick
and when you come back to Melbourne can
i potentially meet you yes hit up Dustin
all right thank you so much really
appreciate it you got it there's
jaren you got it take your brother [ __ ]
Dustin give me send me that URL I typed
it in wrong I found some lady in Alabama
all right let's keep it going hello it's
hanging in what's your name normal time
but I was so nervous I remember okay so
my kids told me not to blow it today so
three kids so it's been quite the
weekend um I have an Instagram account
my story isn't finished and basically I
put little blurbs every day positive or
certain life lessons that I put out
there with humor I've had so many people
message me saying you know you could
make a write a book or put a book
together or something so I was wondering
if I you know if I gathered all that
information should I self-published or
how do you self publish or should i blog
more yep do you why do you want to write
a book
well tons of journals from when I was
little I have a book of poems I have and
this is what I go back to you when I'm
trying to look for content when I'm
putting it out and I put things out that
are real I put everything that I put out
it has happened to me in some way shape
or form mistakes fun stuff embarrassing
stuff and because I'm in my 50s I I've
had all these life lessons and there's
so many things that have happened bad
things to that people it doesn't define
you you know and when I put these out
I'll get messages like Wow Norma you
know what maybe I can do this after all
no I decided for example last year to
enter the Half Ironman
out of the blue I decided okay I need to
do this has been on my bucket list I did
it not knowing how to swim not knowing
how to bike and I ran 30 years ago was
the last time I ran look at me I did
Capri in 8 hours and 11 minutes no why
Norma what why do you want to write the
book like let's go let's go let's go
very like to the punchline is it because
like it will help me give you the answer
that I have which is why great great so
go to go I got you
so I want you to go to this website
called Google and so you need so you
need to type how do I self publish what
I would probably put in is how do I self
publish on Amazon yep and I think by
this afternoon you'll know how and just
like you figured out the Half Ironman
you'll do this and the reason you want
to write is you have something to say
and away we go
what I have to say out there and do i do
I just focus on Instagram and just start
a little bit you know on all the other
social media you know this is you know I
I will be consistent till the day I die
on this it is about putting out
information podcast YouTube Twitter
tick-tock snapchat like it is forever
and ever it going to be the answer
people struggle with not having an
audience I preferred it let me let me
let me let me let me stay there for a
second because it's a super important
point people don't go to other platforms
most of everybody here isn't signing up
or Twitter right now or isn't going
there because it's hard to amass an
audience there because they don't like
the feeling of what they think is
wasting their time by posting something
where nobody's listening that's look the
punchline is figure out which medium
works for you written word audio video
and then because much of it as possible
in as many places that you possibly can
do it for as long as possible and then
pop up your head in three years and see
if that's giving you the leverage to do
the thing that you theoretically think
you want to do the point I was making
earlier but I preferred it is I like the
process more than the affirmation and
the accolades and the successes that
come along with it until people figure
that out they will continue to be
insecure audacious ego led to why
they're not setting up accounts in other
places well once you set up those
accounts and do it for a long period of
time you build enough of an audience
that when you then tell them you're the
self-published book it will convert
everything I had the straight childhood
because I from another country yes that
was the first 30 years of my life and
then it wasn't until I moved away to
Saudi Arabia that I was actually able to
grow because I didn't have to worry
about the judgment and stuff and I get
all those type followers and then I've
got the older age group and then I've
got the moms you know why are you
letting your kids listen to Gary because
my kids are 13 or 14
they don't understand that I'm like well
my kids hadn't listened to your if I
hadn't listened to you then one of my
kids wouldn't be doing so well in school
because he absolutely hated school
because I was like school school school
because that's how I was raised and so
to get past all that and of course again
this is what I write about or blog about
and and people are just like you know
you need to tell people more and so you
know maybe I do have something that is
relatable to people to want to read or
listen to or what yeah yeah I think
you're I think the game is completely
strictly about you not overthinking it
and you're just executing like you did I
think Ironman is the comp you know I
think you're caught up in what 99.9% of
society's caught up in right now which
is metrics of audience there's there's
people written books that had zero
followers on social media when the book
came out and wrote best-selling books
George Lucas had zero fans when he
launched Star Wars like you know my
point my point there Norma is if that's
that was actually the case you wouldn't
be asking the question right like like
that was my case and guess what I never
[ __ ] asked anybody anything I never
read anything about anything I never hit
up anything about anything I [ __ ] did
it if that was the case you would just
do it what time is it right now 4:40 in
the afternoon yes you know like you
wouldn't be sitting in 4:40 p.m. in
Saudi Arabia asking this question you
just be working on making more stuff
yeah that that got it that's it
awesome finally you didn't blow it this
time tell your kids good see ya
look the normal exchange is super
important
like people convincing themselves of
things that aren't true to fit the
narrative they want the formula is super
basic the more true you can go with the
excuse me with the content the more
likely it has an opportunity to hit
somebody because it's authentic you're
now no longer selling vanilla the reason
so many people lose on Instagram for
example with motivational content is
because it's not their truth you just
think it works because they've seen four
or five other people hit with it and
then you just got a contextual you
distribute it across all the platforms
that have the attention it's really
simple there's what's stopping you is
not simple it's grounded in childhood
it's grounded in so many variables
environment chemicals DNA like but like
this games simple let's keep it going
hello Garrity this is fun surprise oh
yeah you didn't know I was gonna be on
Friday which was my 30th birthday and
but things are see thank you very much
and contacts for people who are watching
is that I work for Gary in vaynermedia
London Eye vaynermedia LDN on Instagram
if you wanna follow them and I guess
context for you so I've known for a
couple of weeks that I was gonna be on
cuz I asked saying as a cheeky birthday
favor em and I know you've talked a
bunch even today about sort of doing
things that your truth so a few months
ago I started a website aimed at helping
people get hired by top companies
because it's something I sort of felt I
was good at and now obviously working
for you um ultimate TV template calm the
website still exists and wants to check
it out bullet I've been thinking about
it alas so that's not what the questions
about because I've pivoted so I've been
into painting for like five years on and
off as you can see behind yes and but in
the last like since laughter and began
I've just become like freakishly I
really like and I used so I did kung-fu
for about 12 years now a black belt in
Kung Fu and maybe bar alcohol
this is the thing that I've found myself
most in love with and I stopped drinking
this year so I need a new hobby and so
and I've done a lot of research in the
build of this because I wanted to sort
of have the context and what you think
so I looked at every question about art
and stuff they even asked us Eric Lee
and in 2016 you said there's tens of
thousands of artists who will give up on
their craft and never make it who would
be millionaires if they were your
business partner so if we imagine this
was our first meeting as your business
partner and you're giving me advice for
the next 10 years try to like build
something what would your advice be to
give your art to the to the most
widely-known influencers on the
platforms that matter the most I would
make art I would post on my Instagram
everywhere for that matter I would make
a tick-tock of me making it and then I
would give that art upfront to you know
the charlie'd Emilio's the whoever they
may be your favorite footballer you know
whoever you know literally DMing and and
you hit up 45 people 580 players in the
Premier League and one says yes and then
that one person doesn't even post it on
their Instagram or their story and
you're devastated because you finally
got a yes and you do that over and over
and over until you have your quote
unquote break what you have in real life
cause you have me right like if you know
your ability with which your Instagram
handle Angus Boyle so things what what
what's gonna happen now is you're gonna
take one of those photos literally
literally post it on your Instagram
right now after this call because a
bunch of people are following you right
now and come up with some sort of price
like three hundred thirteen dollars
three hundred thirty two IR I I when D
designs is on on Friday and ship them
for her I realized how big an
opportunity to show so I built a website
over the weekend an arbitrarily priced
the art so what's your my youngest um
art by a horse come super smart doesn't
get on that real quick so like yeah I
mean very honestly your careers started
right now like here it is you know I
think you need a lot of my fans are
American based oh this is wildly global
you'll have to figure you make sure you
don't get killed on shipping luckily
it's probably is your art
papers that on campus like how heavy is
it and the bigger ones are all on canvas
I made some super light ones on
cardboard love it like you know like
look I think this is how it works bro
nice dude like this is amazing keep
scrub I thought you were painting with
your feet for a second I was not to go
crazy haha I'm scrolling Dustin yes he
like like honestly you're gonna sell
these things right now like it's just
gonna happen and and I think it's
[ __ ] amazing and you ship everywhere
yeah I'll have to figure that brother I
honestly I think I think to be very
frank I think your career the the end of
your vaynermedia career in the beginning
of your art career might be happening
literally in this moment and that makes
me so [ __ ] happy like first of all
you're really good I'm proud of you
brilliant it's really good
hits small or medium sorry yeah man I
mean obviously you've got a lot of good
vibe stuff too which is gonna do well
with my audience and then you know like
this is just how it is man like every
art like if Jay Leno wasn't pushed by
his management you know he would have
never been who he was like some people
are the art and then some people need a
break some people need a partner in
crime somebody needs a cosign you have
the luxury being great executive at our
company that makes me desperately try to
get everybody to buy a PC or art right
now and so you built up that leverage
with somebody who can give you that
cosign there's a lot of people right now
who don't have me or anything that looks
like me in their world so what they have
to do is kind of what I did I mean my
cosign in a lot of ways was diggnation
right like like it was kevin rose and
alex albrecht who kind of gave me a
shout out on diggnation in like
2005-2006 internet and that kind of was
my little spark and you know it always
happens it happens all the time and so
you know hopefully this is beginning of
yours thank you so much for Livi they
let me back then take care of talk to
you soon all right it was a fun surprise
good job doesn't think it's good people
real good people all right let's keep it
going
hi Gary good morning good morning
brother how do you pronounce your name
aligned like
yeah like a straight line like yeah cool
you know house porn thing going pretty
well how about for you I'm in Tucson
Arizona so I'm enjoying the heat while
being quarantined so it's been good okay
two questions for you related to each
other but I want to start off by telling
you a little bit about the project that
I have going on right now so I got into
the real estate industry to build spec
houses and so that's been going well I
built one and I sold the first house um
I financed that with the help of my dad
he let me you know he supported me and
he lent me some money and I rolled that
one and now I'm on to the second house
so that's been good but obviously I want
to get to the point where I'm building
you know 20 houses 50 houses 100 houses
at a time and belting I've got patients
I've got time I'm in college I'm a 20
year old college student so I guess like
my question for you is as a 20 year old
college student how do I go out there
and find investors how do I go out there
and find cash because I personally don't
have enough cash in the quest by
spending no time convincing people so to
turn that I'm it I'm gonna bring that
down there's a 22 percent chance I would
give you money when I'm most liquid
there's a zero percent chance that 99%
of people would give you money there's a
whole group of people that would
actually give you money you need to
figure it out right like you do you you
know obviously knock on wood thank God
you had a situation where your father
could help you a little bit so I'm sure
it's running through your mind your dad
probably runs in some circles where you
can go into that world do you even want
to go there how much do you want to feel
like you built this on your own two feet
not with your dad that's always a tough
thing for a 20 year old I I struggled
with going into my dad even though I was
going to go into my dad business to help
him build his business
I even struggled with that so I
understand that but the other thing I'm
I don't see that as a problem I guess
like I've always been very close to mine
so crumb I'm sure dad has I'm sure your
dad has friends it all depends it all
depends on your consciousness so for
example I am NOT great at raising money
because I don't I don't mind losing
every dollar I have but in my DNA I
struggle with the idea of losing other
people's money right so like that that's
a shortcoming of mine in some ways
because it's led to me leaving money on
the table where I could raise capital
the other thing is I think you map the
500 richest people in Arizona in in you
know and you know do you go to see Anna
Clara yeah I go exactly
I would I would Google you know most
successful alumni is from Santa Clara
history enter see the whole list then
hit him up on LinkedIn and and in saran
the punchline is you just keep asking
until someone says yes instead of
dwelling on the people that are saying
no I think you get as many 5-minute
conversations as possible and the second
you know that the person's not
interesting or they're just you know
there's been meetings that people have
taken because somebody else co-signed me
and I wanted to have the meeting and
literally I jumped out of the meeting
within five minutes cuz I could realize
that the person was there just because
the other person asked them and they
weren't interested and I wasn't
interested in wasting my time let alone
theirs
okay so basically just go out there and
you know hustle and reach reach as many
people as I can an unconscious framework
unconscious like just completely
unemotional unconscious robotic
framework of giving your best pitch and
having no feelings goose egg
zero [ __ ] feelings when somebody's
like not interested you're too young you
know I don't trust you yeah and you know
you get a lot of kids ask me like how do
I get people to respect me you don't you
can't change the fact that you're 20 and
you look 16 okay that's not that's not
changing
yeah right and so I lived that like yes
Dustin looking like 16 your videos
coming in a little choppy so cool mine
yeah now it's better because once like I
said the wind wants the windows keep
them alternating it gets better but yeah
now you're good
aligned I think um I think it's about
zero emotion I don't know so the know
everybody like 98% of this audience
right now in the comments
all of their struggles comes because
they're emotional about them no and then
they [ __ ] try to convince like Uncle
Harry or [ __ ] rich man Magoo in town
why they're the right thing don't
convince the non commensal yeah is that
is that so like I guess like that kind
of covers my second question for you is
that the same answer you would give me
as to how do i scale this at this stage
in my life how do i guess yeah scale
scale is single-handedly your biggest
vulnerability the addiction for scale in
the business world right now has
completely [ __ ] everyone the amount of
businesses that are about to go out of
business in this next year because they
overvalued scale when they had something
is remarkable wine text right obviously
in a year you'll be able to sign up and
I appreciate that you know
I'm scaling it slowly the economics have
to work I can run ads crazy till I get
more users and scale and but then it's
but the economics aren't there and the
vulnerability would become there and I'd
rather be the [ __ ] tortoise align I'm
telling you right now bro like you need
to figure out why honestly why do you
want to scale your own insecurities and
want to show everybody you can do it by
yourself just because you think it's
right because all the [ __ ] Elon
Musk's and shmear on Bucks and Beyond
Bucks are telling you your dad told you
so you read one book and you [ __ ]
thought it was cool you you want as much
money as possible to hook up with you
know people because you're gonna use the
money to like hook up like I don't know
why but you need to realize that scale
when you have this little experience is
[ __ ] dangerous so it's all about that
macro patience you always talk about but
working 17 hours a day bleeding out if
you're that [ __ ] ambitious and it
makes you that happy so that much so
that micro speed that macro patience
it's my most important framework because
if you're happy and you know a lot of
people don't you know Micro they burn
themselves out because actually don't
like it they just wanted the money yeah
you know the scale the money the win the
cover of Entrepreneur Magazine those are
all the poisons
cliche it's true his [ __ ] I've watched
it for the last 20 years I've seen so
many my friends look like they were
winning raise a ton of capital [ __ ]
be the dominators at South by Southwest
and four years later be out of a job
yeah now just I've seen this rodeo bro
no you know I lived it when you were
born you know so like I watched it so I
just I don't want you to put scale on a
pedestal I want you to put I want you to
put a foundation on the pedestal I said
I see what you're saying
so I don't want too much of your time
well it's okay um you know so I I was in
Tony Robbins I've gone to one of his
seminars and he talks a lot about you
know winter winter is my season so so
how do you leverage you know the the
environment that we're living in right
now
per say I don't know I don't know I
apologize what does that mean does that
mean the tough times uh well first of
all you got really lucky because a lot
of people who are 30 who did over
leveraged themselves never saw tough
times from 20 to 30 and they didn't
realize they existed I mean people are
getting slayed right now like it's kind
of hidden right now cuz there's still
some bailouts and we're not back to real
life but I'm telling you right now bro
some of those coolest people on
Instagram and on the internet are gonna
be real real real real quiet in December
in February and next March a year from
today you know because like people are
out yeah it's not just j.crew yes just
happy
yeah no reason you know so so you know I
think that for you I don't think you can
take advantage of this time requires
liquid if you want to do it financially
yeah so people are sending a ton of cash
you're gonna buy up [ __ ] cheap or it's
gonna require realizing this is a great
moment to foundationally teach you that
getting over-leveraged because you
valued scale over fundamentals is
something you don't want to do make
sense make sense awesome thank you I
appreciate the help well since I'm not
gonna get to another one I'm gonna talk
to Dustin let me keep you here for one
more second right any insight to why you
want scale um you know I mean I'm not
desperate for scale right now I guess
maybe I didn't communicate that because
I know I'm I'm not I'm young like I'm 20
years old I'm a sophomore in college I
have no need to be the biggest you know
real estate Curie more out of curiosity
of how to do it yeah it's more out of
you know like I got the opportunity to
talk to you I want to see you know what
you know what the funny answer is it's
still the same answer okay yeah no yeah
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna bill I'm
gonna build the biggest [ __ ] scale of
all time
and I worked in a liquor store when I
was 32 yeah I mean that what you're
saying I see what you're saying
it makes them know yeah because if you
know to me it's just like people are
confused and how long this game is
mm-hmm I'm 24 years older than you yeah
you were negative [ __ ] 4 mm-hmm you
know like you know like when I was your
age you were negative [ __ ] 4 yeah
I've got time I've got time
no no no no you have I don't come you
know think of in a sporting analogy you
haven't even woke up from your bed and
drove to the stadium yet you're still
[ __ ] sleeping in your bed the day of
the game if once you actually I believe
the single biggest strength I have is my
relationship with time because once you
have that relationship with time all the
[ __ ] that comes out of my mouth makes a
lot more sense if you actually
understood that you were gonna live for
100 more years then you will [ __ ]
really start thinking about [ __ ]
differently and you won't make the moves
of the cliche 27 year old that's got it
like that there's been a lot of the
lines that have lost because they have
it like that their circumstance worked
out with family they themselves have it
and they got confident between 20 and 27
and then they went in for the kill and
it killed them I
all those guys and difference between
those guys and me and others is that
patience and then when you know you know
I put all my liquid assets into [ __ ]
Facebook all of them but Facebook
flopped over at zero but it was written
there was no risk I was too experienced
at the time I was that was already 10
years into my game I'd seen email I'd
seen [ __ ] Google AdWords I'd seen
YouTube MySpace friends like I seen it I
met sucks
I hung for a year and a half I watched
the executives a new boss I [ __ ] knew
Dave Morin
I knew the culture I knew the product I
watched I looked at the Mac I wasn't
guessing I wasn't thinking in theory I
was relying on experience and then I
struck like a [ __ ] Cobra got it
I got me ready your moment will you
there you will have 30 moments and ones
like this is my moment
mm-hmm if you're good enough you'll have
30 [ __ ] moments yeah super food got
you that is a show today sorry about the
video [ __ ] up yeah it just comes in a
little blurry but I mean it wasn't like
cutting in and out or anything it was
just blurry how about when I said
[ __ ] struck like a Cobra
yeah I think it was blurry still blurry
right now
one second you know what's not blurry
wine text calm that's true $65 read for
20 [ __ ] $8 today Dustin mm-hmm
please sign up for wine text calm it is
literally the single best service of all
time see ya I realize
a lot of you that watch tea with garyvee
aren't signed up for my podcast that
makes me sad here's what you're missing
out on know you like helped me so much
thank you for and like you know
navigating like it's all mine Satya
preaching like when I when I enter
college I had such a bad mindset yeah
because I was like you know I don't
really want to be here I just won't work
yeah but like listening to a podcast
every day having like positivity of my
ears is really just like holds me alone
Gary if the mindset has been skewed how
can you bring it back and I answered
with by surrounding yourself with people
who have the mindset you aspire to mold
and I mean mold your mindset by what you
consume and with whom you consume if you
think you're like this [ __ ] you're like
the [ __ ] people are sending to more of
my content you need [ __ ] positivity
coming through your ears then [ __ ]
all that negativities come in your head
put your [ __ ] headphones in and
listen to positivity if you can't move
out yet put [ __ ] in your ears you walk
in put the [ __ ] headphones on in your
house close your door and [ __ ] listen
you can listen while you're driving you
can listen while you're traveling you
can listen while you're working out you
can listen while you're walking the dog
like find your [ __ ] like don't listen
the [ __ ] the people that [ __ ] on you
like get in your own head put positivity
around you drop these or friends like
that negativity that you're hearing
you've got to get that the [ __ ] out of
your life you need to put your [ __ ]
ear plugs in and listen to positive 24/7
understand when their surroundings are
[ __ ] you're in
sighs I'll be positive bacteria here
means your [ __ ] halfway
[Music]
you
[Music]